foreign
Tracy is with us in Orange County
California hi Tracy welcome to the
Ramsey Show
you guys are not going to be as proud of
me as you were the first two callers
okay try to bring it down oh well
there's Tracy and then there's Tracy
okay
okay so I've got a Bonus coming next
month about thirteen thousand dollars
way to go about 19. well here's where it
goes down I've of about nineteen
thousand dollars in credit card debt
with 17 cards open and I pay about 754 a
month on those cards now yes my husband
is not happy with me at all so yeah he's
the saver my question is do I pay off as
many of the lowest cards as possible
and 30 on the bigger ones I'm trying to
figure out what I should do with my
bonus money to get rid of as much of
this debt as possible
okay
um
let's answer that but let's kind of
circle around it for a second before we
do it okay because because it does
affect uh the importance of the answer
no it won't change the answer but
um
are you done
yes
you're done you cut them all up I'm done
you hesitated they are they are all cut
up every one of them no well I had to
think about it for a second but I'm
looking at them right now in the trash
my husband and I have had many heated
discussions about it and oh I don't want
to waste money about this has become a
this has become a thing okay it has
become a very serious thing okay and uh
are you two now gonna move from uh him
having serious discussions at his wife's
credit card debt to now working together
and handling money together and never
going back here again
I'm done well I I I want you to be able
to continue to enjoy money as a as a
vote on the budget that you do together
but that will also ensure some
accountability that you're asking for
and willing to do for not over spending
but I still want you to be able to spend
we don't want to go all the way to his
side and you have no oil at all on the
joints and start to squeak
you know what I'm saying yeah so
enjoyment of money is part of the
process as well it's not uh but but
overdoing it obviously is not the
process so having said all that that's
important because
um if you're not doing the things that
we've been talking about for the last
few moments no answer to your 13 000 is
going to work because this crap is going
to grow back
exactly okay so that's why I wanted to
set the table there for that so having
said all of that then let's just list
them smallest to largest regardless of
the interest rate balance smallest
largest balance and pay off as many as
13 will do you said there's 17 cards
I'll bet you that gets rid of uh 14 of
them
well I've got eight that are under one
thousand dollars and I've gotten nine
okay so we know we got eight of them
that's eight thousand and then there's
another five thousand so I'm gonna be
pretty close
might be 13 instead of 14 but depending
on how those balances land but the good
news is and I tell you I I have sat with
people Tracy in the past like years ago
when I first started doing this and I
was amazed at what it does to your
emotions like when we would make a list
of all of their debts smallest to
largest and then we would look over and
say Hey you have eleven thousand dollars
in a savings account and they would have
these people maybe in the in those
situations have a little 75 dollar
medical bill from diagnostic because if
you drive near a hospital they send you
a 75 diagnostic bill that you don't even
have to go in you just drive past they
send you a bill it's like automatic it's
like a camera on the car and so you know
you get all these little mosquito bills
I call them little tiny ones and we make
a there'd be a list of 30 or 40 things
when people first start this that have
been just hanging around because they
were disorganized and chaotic and we
would take ten thousand dollars and wipe
out like three quarters of the list and
it feels like you did more than you
actually did did mathematically you see
what I'm saying yes and when you knock
out uh 13 14 of these things you're
gonna you're gonna get that sense of
emotional momentum yeah and Tracy I'm
going to challenge you I mean first of
all every penny so make sure you hear us
every penny of the 13 so that's going to
leave you with six thousand dollars left
and I would keep the momentum going
because I think you're going to get a
real uh shot of dopamine when you strike
a check and you cut it down to six grand
but I mean I would be doing selling
things I would be looking for extra
opportunity to make some money and and
put it on paper just as you list out all
of them knock out the rest of it real
fast how quickly can I knock out the six
thousand and if I think if you do that
before we cut the check for 13 so it all
happens one two punch I think you're
gonna be surprised how quick you knock
out the six it's going to change your
marriage it's going to change all this
emotion that's been around these heated
conversations yeah congratulations yeah
and we're thankful to have you in the
listening audience and proud of you as
you say Dave she's sick and tired of
being tired yeah that's when when you
finally say I've had it yeah that's when
you're ready to change until you're
ready until you had your I've had it
moment and she has yeah you can tell and
no one can have it for you isn't that
the truth your husband can't have it for
you that's right you know it's true you
know I now value my marriage and the
quality of my marriage not just my
marriage but the quality of my marriage
above the the spending pattern I've had
it yeah and and that's a that's a that's
an adult decision right there it's not a
baby so she said we weren't going to be
as proud over as the other two I'm proud
of her yeah yeah I agree I think you're
doing really good I absolutely agree
because you know in some ways the the
the Constitution that it takes
emotionally mentally you're gonna have
to really go after this change the way
you live and think uh that's to be
admired Tracy it's to be admired that's
uh change isn't easy transformation is
one of the hardest things humans do oh
yeah yeah so you know it's interesting
you're talking about this idea that
um go ahead and lay out the plan for the
other six thousand that's very so
there's two things here yeah you guys
need to listen in here very clearly if
you're fighting debt number one when you
pay off smallest to largest you get a
positive feedback loop okay this is
telling you you're winning you're
winning you're winning you're winning
you're winning there's a light at the
end of the tunnel that's not an oncoming
train and so you will keep with
something that gives you a positive
feedback loop that's a psychological
phrase go look it up okay so if you if
you're getting if you're getting some
wins if you go on a diet and you lose
weight you'll keep doing it if you're
going to die and you gain two pounds you
quit negative feedback loop positive
feedback loop okay so you need things
there the second thing that happens is
and we do it here on the air with people
and they don't even realize we're doing
it to them is that when you lay out the
math for the first time
and you go huh
I really can do that in about four
months wow I never about Christmas were
that the math when you lay out a plan
even though you've absolutely done
nothing yet you just laid out a plan
that's all you did you just recognized
it is doable yes but you've actually
done nothing
your stress goes way down yeah because
your hope goes way up oh it's so true
and that's from a power of focus you
know when we know from psychology
research that when we focus on something
intently we begin to see it everywhere
the example that they've given research
studies is when you go buy a car last
time you bought a car live studio
audience you can play along with me here
you remember commenting on how you saw
that blue minivan or whatever you bought
everywhere over the next week even your
kids were like hey there's our car well
the god of cars didn't just drop them in
on the road it's that you focus so
intently on a purchase like this that we
begin to see it and as you described
when we begin to see that I can pay it
off in four months six months 10 months
here's what happens you begin to truly
see the opportunities to make more money
to cut expenses everywhere and it
becomes so believable and that's what
makes it so achievable because all of a
sudden you go wait a second this is this
is I can do this and the power of belief
is in stock yeah hope yeah it's hope I I
could see it that's exactly was I I
actually have hope in an area I've never
been good at money I've always been
behind on my bills it's always been
chaotic you have all these negative
self-talk things all these negative
messages and some of you if you talked
to my friend the way you talk to
yourself I would smack you you don't
talk to people I like like that no don't
talk to yourself that way be nicer to
yourself and let's get the negative
thing out there and it's not it's not a
heebie-jeebie mysterious stuff it's just
like gosh I can actually do this